She
and they made a a new show out of that
and of course it had all the LGBT stuff
in it. She had she has a girlfriend that
she kisses and all that.
Yeah.
In the '8s
and the new one the new
Yeah. Yeah.
I was like
they got they got that kind of stuff
Arthur now.
Yeah. They include the representation
now or else you'll be cancelled.
Yeah.
[Music]
Today we're going to show our age.
Yeah,
we're getting into the 80s cartoons.
We're going to be talking about
different things. And I know we
showing to you guys something blue
characters. But it was very interesting.
I just had this style about like what
about this blue character? What about
this? You know, this movie had this
character is blue. why is all these
different gods and and I was like, well,
let's put it this thing together and
we'll see how it goes.
Okay.
And it's kind of interesting. So, I have
a question for you guys. Where do you
think is
Satan right now and his angels?
Where do I think he is?
Yeah.
Uh, Antarctica.
Or the Arctic.
I think he's in the White House. In the
White House.
Yeah.
You think he's in the White House?
Or the UN?
Yeah. Yeah,
just to keep
wherever Reed thinks he's needed most
the ISS
you know we exposing you know all the
entertainment industry and all stuff and
Hollywood I mean it's just crazy stuff's
coming out you know a lot of things but
let me tell you the Bible says very
clear in Revelation 1279
and it was a war broken in heaven
Michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon and his angels
fought back that he was not strong
enough and they lost their place in
heaven. And the great dragon was hurt
down an ancient serpent called the devil
and Satan who leads the whole world
astray and he was cast out to the earth
and his angels with him. The devil and
his angels there. They're here in the
earth.
Yeah, definitely.
And let me tell you what you were saying
about the the UN and and maybe in
Hollywood or somewhere else in the
world. It's like
he's somewhere
somewhere, right? And if we put a a a
place that
the enemy, you know, the devil is just
we see a lot of negativity
like a lot of, you know, against the
word of God, against the principle, you
know, God is love, you know, all the
stuff like where is it?
Everywhere, right? Like everywhere music
all around the world.
Yeah. Yeah.
It says that he he deceives the world.
Yeah. That's why it was like wherever
he's needed most. I mean, you kind of
see a picture in
Daniel chapter 10 where Daniel has been,
you know, praying and fasting for like
three weeks trying to get an answer on
on something and and and
he couldn't break through because
essentially, you know, like Satan was
interfering. He goes on and then um
picking up in
uh verse
I want to say yeah like 12 this angel
comes and starts talking to him. Then he
says to me do not fear Daniel for from
the first day that you set your heart to
understand and to humble yourself before
God your words were heard. Which is very
comforting. So it's you know Daniel's
thinking my prayer is not being
answered. My prayer is not being
answered. But the angel telling him,
"No, look, angels are dispatched right
away."
Wow.
But there was something else going on.
Yeah.
And so it's important to for us to
remember, we might be praying angels are
dispatched right away, but we don't see
any results. Why? Because there's other
things and other forces at play.
There's a real war going on.
It's a real war. It says, "But the
prince of the kingdom of Persia withtood
me 21 days. And behold, Michael, one of
the chief princes, came to help me, for
I had been left alone. Prince of the
kingdom of Persia withtood me. So
withtood that angel is understood in
many theological circles to be Satan,
you know, and he's concentrating his
power and effort on this kingdom at this
point in time. It was it was the most
powerful nation
in the world.
So he's probably wherever the most
powerful kingdom is. And right now, I
mean,
or moving around to wherever he needs to
to to get it done because it's like,
well, obviously he's not probably with
Persia right now. That doesn't make
sense. Like, there are other more
powerful nations,
but you at least see he gets involved in
political powers.
And it operates a lot like the the
military does, I'm sure. There's
generals, there's, you know, people that
are that are just told, you know, go and
accomplish this thing and,
you know, he's overseeing the whole
thing. That's what I think.
Yeah. Yeah. And starting this research
that I was going to uh we did a led uh
talk about avatar,
right? But it's very interesting uh you
know what the Bible said you know that
that Satan is deceiving the whole world
and the thing is that
as like you said powerful people
government kings you know things like
that but we talk about entertainment
industry we talk about who make movies
producers you know or directors you know
writers
very wealthy people with a lot of power
a lot of power,
influence,
influence. And we we did a a LED
about, you know, the dangers of Avatar,
things like that. But, uh, I just want
to show you guys once again how um,
James Cameron had this idea about
Avatar.
Let's watch this clip.
James Cameron talking about where he
gets his inspiration from. Because if he
is in fact being used by the enemy, if
the enemy wanted to use influential
people to try to change the world, to
try and get people to believe a lie that
the dragon is going to deceive the
entire world, then James Cameron would
have to be getting this information from
the spirit world in some way. So, this
is going back to 1976.
I think the thing that's interesting
about it is that I've already got a a
tall hot blue girl in that movie. your
name wasn't Naterian, but I was already
thinking about it then. A lot of stuff
comes to me in dreams and I remember it.
Sometimes I write it down.
Sometimes it's an image
and I'll go I'll go draw or paint that
image.
And I quickly painted as many of them as
I could remember.
One of them was a glowing forest
with a river of light running through it
and trees that kind of looked like fiber
optics.
Well, guess what? Cut to, you know, 30
years later.
I'm making a movie where we're spending
millions of dollars to actually create
that image. But that image came in a in
a dream when I was uh 18 years old.
Now, this is interesting.
This is one of the first pieces of
artwork
that I did for Terminator even before I
wrote it.
And it's the
chromoskeleton coming out of the fire.
That was kind of a defining image.
That's the image that came to me in a
dream in 1981.
I always think of the the universe as
like a a giant bank vault lock, you
know, and the tumblers are constantly
moving and every once in a while the
tumblers line up and you got to listen
for the click. He literally was using
new age terminology here when he says
you got to listen to the universe. The
universe is speaking to you. And James
Cameron is being used in one of the
biggest motion pictures of all time. And
he's getting this information from the
universe and from dreams.
That's pretty.
So he was 18 years old. He got this
dream and later on, you know, he's like,
you know what? I'm going to make this
movie about that.
And we had this avatar. So through a
dream
and he was 18 years old.
You know, I think the devil is just
counterfeiting the things of God, right?
He speaks to men sometimes in dreams and
you know, he relays things that are
going to happen in the future and it's
like these guys I don't think they quite
grasping where this is coming from, you
know?
Yeah. I mean, there's like even just
Terminator. I I didn't realize he wrote
Terminator
and the spiritual concepts in those. I
mean, Terminator,
Judgement Day,
salvation. I mean, those those are like,
you know, straight out of the Bible, but
like sort of like this upside down
version of that. And even Avatar, you
know, the fact that it's a a beautiful
planet with this, you know, everything's
like this crazy beautiful world where
everything gets along except for it
centers around a tree and it's like this
evil, hostile planet. It's like opposite
of what you would read about in the
Bible.
Uh to me it's very interesting. It's
like it's a blue character.
Yeah.
I mean, well, it's not red, green,
brown, or yellow or something like that.
It's a blue character.
I think I agree what you're saying like
u that Satan has a counterfeit, you
know, like I I think we're all kind of
inspired by one way or the other. If we
walk with God, we're always asking him
like, "Lord, uh, you know, give me
inspiration. Speak through me. Your
words, not my words." We're trying to
put less of us into what we create or
speak or preach or whatever, and more of
him. But these people, they're, you
know, they're walking in the world.
They're not seeking God in any kind of
way. So maybe even they're, you know,
using drugs or I'm not saying all of
them, but they're doing things that
could open their mind up to let the
enemy in. and then they wake up having
this dream. Where do dreams come from? I
don't I don't know. I'm not saying all
of them have any kind of significance,
but uh sometimes when it's like that,
like you have a dream about a character
that becomes um one of the best selling
movies of all time,
you have to kind of wonder because
that's happened with Harry Potter as
well. She dreamed about it. Twilight was
a dream, too.
It was it was uh it was similar to JK
Rowling where it was it wasn't like a
nighttime. So JK Rowling didn't see it
at night. It's just kind of like a
vision.
Same with Stephanie Meyer was like just
saw this stuff kind of develop.
She bordered on like automative writing.
She would hear the characters talk and
then she dragged it down.
Whoa, that's real creepy. We need to
make a video on that.
Yeah. And there's another uh documentary
in 1980. It was uh this is a scene from
a revival of evil. And I believe it was
a professor
that he was really want to worship
uh the devil
and he's like you know what I really
want to know who I'm worshiping you know
to and uh revealed to me and stuff like
that but he's a painter too. So he's
like
he was a um a art teacher art college.
Yeah.
Yeah. So he decided like you know I
don't know if you had a dream or
something or you just say like you know
I want to know you know who you are show
me and stuff that so he started painting
this guy
a revival of evil and there was this art
teacher and he gave up on God. He cussed
out God and started worshiping Satan and
he said Satan I want you to show me what
you look like because I want to paint
you and I want to look at that thing as
a visual of who I worship so that it
would give me more faith. And he said he
shut out all the lights, closed all the
blinds, and he pulled out a canvas and
he started painting. And he said every
movement he made was something else
moving him.
Another force was physically directing
my body. Painted for several hours and I
was finished. It was the most fantastic
painting I'd ever done.
And the painting looks just like one of
those beings from the Avatar movies.
That's crazy.
Please pay attention. That's what he
drew, right? He has a little something
in the middle of your eye. Just remember
that third eye. Okay. Third eye, right?
Everything you see and everything,
right?
You will remember later on. I'm gonna
show you something else.
What's interesting is this guy was
getting this
vision and uh painting probably in the
late 70s, early 80s. And I I think that
was like the same time James Cameron was
having that dream. He said it didn't
come till much later because of
the technology, the special effects had
to catch up. But he both of them were
seeing the same thing. This blue woman
like that. What about this one?
Oh, the Smurfs.
Smurfs. I mean, if you 80 kids, I mean,
I'm sure you remember this show.
I was almost joking when I said, "Are we
going to talk about the Smurfs?"
He was serious.
No, he was serious. But
you know, they have this like little
gnome hat.
I mean, isn't there the people that do
the DMT and they go like shoot into
outer space and they get presented by
the little gnomes? Don't they look like
this?
No, that's very interest. Well, yeah,
they do. see like the the elves and
their robot elves and stuff.
They describe them as little gnomes.
But there is a significance about that
red hat like that. It's actually there's
a like a seal that the military uses and
there's like a staff with that red hat
on there and Walter Vith talked about
that.
That's Yeah, that's interesting that you
brought that up.
Interesting.
I love Walter Vith, by the way.
Yeah, check him out.
If you haven't checked out Walter Vice's
material, you should look at this. This
guy deep dives into some crazy stuff.
Definitely.
Yeah, it's so clear. And it's
interesting because the Smurfs, you
know, the the Papa Smurf,
uh, he's a wizard,
right? And all the magic and all stuff.
And you see the titles of the topics,
you know, the cartoon. One of them is
the root of evil,
I mean, children want to listen that
kind of stuff. And they have a song
special. Uh in the 80s they have a
special for Christmas special. You know
sometimes they have a Christmas special
and they you know they talk about that.
You know what I'm talking about that
Christmas special
is the devil show up and told uh uh told
Garl.
Yeah. Told that guy he said you know
what if you want to get uh those SMSs
I'm going to help you how to do it.
I want those children because a real
children you know human children they
were they were going to this castle
whatever and the devil said I want those
those children. So he told Garam you
need to go take care of that business
first get the children
kidnapped for me and I'm going to give
you
the way how to get those smurfs.
Wow. So the Christmas special is
kidnapping cartoon
topic about this mer for Christmas
special.
It was weird. There's a
there's a Christmas song that's like
uh scary ghost stories and there like
for Christmas what? Scary ghost stories.
I guess they're talking about like the
ghost of Christmas past or something
like that. I don't know if you guys
heard but in the in the 80s parents they
were very concerned about the kids that
were watching that stuff because it was
a lot of magical magic things and also I
don't know if you I mean I couldn't find
it because you know nowadays they clean
up the the whole internet just to looks
very nice and clean but let me tell you
I remember that people were had
testimonies of say I saw in my dreams or
like an appearance or something like
that. Like a smurf with red eyes and
things like that. Oh yeah.
Interesting. There there's a lot of
spiritualism in a lot of these things
that we grew up as kids and and you know
I think each generation has battled the
spiritualism topic. It seems to be
getting more and more overtly. But this
this is Yeah. I mean when you go back
and you look at it with a fresh set of
like Christian eyes, you're like, "Wow,
this is kind of really messed up."
Yeah.
Yeah. Remember it's a blue character.
Mhm.
Okay. Well, had this guy got a dream, a
blue character. The guy, the professor,
he want to worship the devil. It's a
blue guy.
Mhm.
A good person.
You know, we did that
stuff on elemental witchcraft and stuff.
Every time I see this kind of stuff now,
I'm like, I wonder if they work that
into Smurfs, right?
Some of this. Yeah, this is from their
their Smurfs fandom wiki. Uh, in the
story of elemental Smurfs, Brainy and
Reader had mistakenly made a spell that
causes all the Smurfs and Smurfetts to
become elementals.
With one half becoming fire, another
water, the other earth, and the last
one, air.
Wow. So, I mean, it it literally says
that the Smurfs are making spells.
Yeah. So, so the Smurfs can use magic.
Yeah.
And Gargaml's a wizard.
So, it's like magic against magic.
So, that's something that we hear a lot.
You know, people are like, "Yeah, but
that that guy, he was the bad guy. That
witch was the bad witch." But oftent
times in the same movie or show or
whatever, how do you fight the witch by
using witchcraft? I mean, that's the way
the Wizard of Oz was. There was the
wicked witch, but it was the good witch
that helped her defeat the bad witch.
Harry Potter, same thing. I'm sure it's
a evil wizard or witch or whatever, but
Harry Potter's a witch.
Mhm.
Yeah. Or a wizard.
Yeah. Same thing in Lord of the Rings,
too. The masses of universe
is blue face.
Okay, except the face, right? But it's a
blue guy, right?
But interesting. The human is the, you
know, you know, the guy who's protecting
the whole universe, right?
Powerful guy, but he has a friend, too.
His name is Orco.
Mhm.
But it's a blue guy, too.
He's a blue wizard.
That is interesting. Also, He-Man is
repping the Maltese cross on his chest,
right?
He rides a beast.
Does he ride a beast as well?
Yeah, he has like that tiger that turns
into like this
bigger tire.
That's right. That's right. I remember
that. The tiger with the armor on his
head.
I used to I used to watch this all the
time as a kid.
Uhhuh. And the Shira, you know, is like
a girl raw. It's probably, you know,
tied back to some Egypt Egyptian stuff.
Is she good?
I don't.
Oh, okay. So, she
and they made a a new show out of that
and of course it had all the LGBT stuff
in it. She had she has a girlfriend that
she kisses and all that.
Oh,
yeah.
In the 80s.
And the new one, the new
Yeah. Yeah.
I was like,
they got they got they got us Arthur
now.
Yeah. They include the representation
now or else you'll be cancelled.
Yeah. No, but let me tell you, you know,
I grew up, you know, with this kind of
mood. I mean four o'clock I mean that
was key man you know and you know things
like that and the thing is that I play
uh that was three years ago before you
know we moved to Tennessee uh uh we used
to have Netflix and one day I was like I
don't know why but I was thinking about
like maybe Netflix they have human
and I was like yeah they have He-Man and
I was like I'm going to play something
you know and I told my girls like hey
girls this is the cartoon I used to
watch you know I'm so proud you know
I used to I start when I was like, you
know, 10 in fourth grade and stuff like
that.
And we just, you know, just play just
the intro
and just a little bit of when I started,
you know, all these, you know, wizards
and practice by the power of gray
school,
you know, all the stuff and the music,
you know, kind of like my girls, dad,
please turn the TV off. What are you
watching? And I'm like, that's my
cartoons when I was growing. No, that's
so evil,
nostalgic, but you know,
I mean, they didn't grow up watching
that kind of stuff. So,
yeah, they had a higher sensitivity to
it. We
Yeah, like Keith said, nostalgia. You
know, we think of something like, "Oh,
that takes me back to a time that was
simpler and times were good and and we
think it was a good thing and you watch
it, you're like, whoa, there was a lot
of stuff in here I didn't catch when I
was a kid."
Yeah. Don't they call this the guy his
their sorcerer friend?
Yeah, the sorcerer friend.
The sorcerer friend.
So, he's the one that's helping Yeah,
there's a blue guy.
Thought of another blue guy.
Uhoh.
Blue's clues.
Captain Planet.
They literally use the elements. They s
earth, wind, fire, water, and he rises
out of the earth.
And he's a blue guy.
The way it opens cuz I I played that
trailer recently for an audience and
they're like, "The Earth is in trouble,
you know."
Oh, yeah. You got the whole climate
change agenda.
Yes.
And the blue guy is going to save
humanity. Wow.
And blue alien avatar.
The fifth element is they call it heart.
So they don't say spirit and they try to
make it sound like good and stuff.
Well, yeah. They always, you know,
follow your heart. If you put the heart
in there, it's okay. So, what about this
guy?
Wow.
Oh, he's the bad guy.
Oh, yeah. Megamind. I didn't even think
about that being blue. His head looks
like the alien head.
Oh, he's an alien.
Interesting.
But it's the evil guy, right?
I mean, bad blue and brilliant.
We we we, you know, we did an LED on
this, I think. No, we got that Magic
Kingdom.
Was this in the Magic Kingdom? Okay, so
check it out in the Magic Kingdom.
But there is an LED extracted from it.
So he he's an alien that they say is
brilliant and we know Satan's very
smart.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's another character
once again and the movie, but let me
tell you in that this Megamind is about
that these guy the superhero guy is not
available when Destruction the savior.
Yeah, he's the he's the typical arch
savior and then he doesn't want to do it
anymore.
He's walking on water,
you know, all the types of
of Jesus, right?
They named a day after him. He was born.
Remember, he came to Earth on Christmas
Day.
Yeah.
There's a lady in Guardians of the
Galaxy, too.
Oh, interesting. Yep. Yep.
She looks like an alien.
I don't remember her name. Yes.
Mhm.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. And you were talking about the
fifth element.
You're right.
Fifth element.
This lady, that's the one we were
talking about. Yeah.
Do you remember her name? Anyways,
Oh, she wasn't. No, that was the blue
one. Yeah, the diva.
The sing she was a singer, right? A
diva.
Yeah.
Plava Lagona. And interesting here it
says her voice when it speaks is musical
and like any human voice overlay. So
that it seems that there are two voices
speaking at the same times. Wow.
All right. And right here in the bottom,
it says, "The diva is quite graceful and
her footsteps could not be heard as she
walks."
That sounds like Satan,
you know. I don't know. I mean, it is uh
it is interesting. It's talking about
musical because Satan, his body is made
up of musical instruments. Here in
Ezekiel 28:13, it it's says, "Thou hast
been in Eden, the garden of God. Every
precious stone was thy covering. The
sardius, topaz, and the diamond, the
barrel, the onyx, and the jasper and
sapphire and emerald, and the carbuncle,
and gold. The workmanship of thy tabets
and of thy pipes was prepared in the day
that thou was created. Tabts and pipes
are like musical instruments that were
built into his body.
Wow.
And I can just imagine, you know, when
he was speaking, it was probably
musical. music is very seductive. It's
uh in influential, you know, and imagine
he's talking to Eve and just being like,
"Eat that fruit or whatever," you know,
be crazy like it was like like a a beat
box or something that's like coming out
and music like we situation depend
situation.
Yo yo yo yo, eat this fruit.
Yeah, it looks so juicy and fun.
You know, I'm like a very
I can't even pretend to flow.
Evil uh piano playing. But it's very
interesting. and he said, you know, her
footsteps could not be heard as she
walks.
I mean, snakes, you know, like this, you
know.
Well, the director, Luke Basson, um, he
has directed quite a few movies that
really deal with very Gnostic themes.
So, you know, whenever I see a pattern
like that of a director or somebody
that's kind of like gravitating sort
towards a similar kind of idea and it
keeps popping up, that tells me that
he's either part of the occult, sold out
to the new age or something that he's
really pushing that
asking the spirit world.
Yeah. Getting dreams.
Yeah. You know, and it's like like we
would make a video and, you know, we're
trying to constantly frame Christianity
in that worldview and and to share with
people, you know, things of the Bible or
this or that. He's excited about what he
believes and and this junk's just a
deception, you know.
Yeah, totally. Uh what about this guy?
The movie Aladdin, you
know, very famous Disney. Yeah. Jean is
blue.
Yeah. You know, genie comes from the
root word jin. Uh it's like a Islamic
word for the genie and the bottle kind
of a thing. And it means any class of
spirits lower than the angels that are
um
it's like demons.
Yeah, they're demons basically.
The root of that word jin is basically
demon.
You are right because I have a video
about that.
Nice.
Wow.
Jin are basically the bogeyman of the
Muslim world haunting the Middle East,
Asia, and parts of Africa today just as
they have done for centuries. It may be
related to the old Iranian giny, a
wicked female spirit. But it entered
English as genie, which in line with the
Latin word genus refers to a guardian
spirit.
Take you in a journey, a world that is
unknown to many people. A world that
only few people were able to dig down
and see the reality of it. It has been
through the history of mankind
that people will always ask and question
themselves about this unusual
phenomenon.
And this is the world of demons, the
world of Jesus.
Wow. Yeah. I mean, in the Islamic
culture, I mean, they speak of these
things all the time. And it's
interesting. Obviously, um, Aladdin was
was sort of a Middle Eastern
character and and they put it in there
and we we think ah it's just this funny
story.
Yeah. Like not realizing like dude, this
is a straight demon that that we're
pushing out to the kids.
A dream of genie.
Yeah. You know,
was she blue?
No.
Yeah. Because I have another video. It
talks about confirm about Muslim. the
real belief about gene demons and
everything like that
that the number of angels is far greater
than the number of jin and that's
something very profound if you think
about it
gins are a a a type of angels uh so
they're within the sub a subset of
angels and so being from among the gins
is also a kind of among the angels
so yeah he said there's more of the good
angels than the jin which you know only
a third of the angels fell
is Jin and falling angel. They're
talking about this equals what? Demons.
Demon. Yeah.
So, I mean, we're Can you imagine these
things are just popping up that and the
children they're just watching and they
say, "You know what? Genius, the one is
helping you to go through life."
I mean, practically, that's what the
movie is, right?
Yeah. To to essentially gratify your
selfish desires.
Yeah. Because when when you always see
people, you know, you get three wishes.
What do they always do? Like
I want lot of me money, you know,
or I want
some amazing, you know, wife or girl or
it's always stuff like that. It's never
like, you know what, let me just end
world hunger.
Yeah.
Do something for someone else.
It's a counterfeit for it's a
counterfeit of prayer. the wish, you
know, like I'll grant your wishes. We
should be teaching kids.
Yeah.
Jiminy Cricket JC
JC. Yeah. Jesus Christ. Jiminy Cricket.
And he's the one that said to wish upon
a star.
But yeah, you know, we should be
teaching kids if you want something or
it's in alignment with God's will, you
know, pray for that. Instead, it's like,
no, this genie can answer any wish you
want.
What about when you use your birthday?
It has a little candle there. Make a
wish.
Make a wish. Yeah. Uh
oh.
Now we going different.
Another show right there.
I never really thought about that. Wish
upon a star. You know stars in the
Bible. I think it's Revelation 12 verse4
I think is the one that says his tale
drew a third part of the stars of heaven
and did cast them down to earth.
You know, it's like interesting
interesting to to promote to wish upon a
star. It's like
wow. in a biblical sense that that
that's
and where do you you you look at
cartoons and stuff and you look at the
little wizards hats that they have for
everything and it always has like stars
and moon and astrological stuff on it.
Wow man.
Yeah.
A lot of times on the end of a magic
wand there's a star.
Well, let me tell you guys we have an
amazing documentary. It's called Magic
Kingdom. If you haven't checked it out,
we have on DVD and also in digital
because everything goes digital. Go
check them out. go and Vimeo or Little
Life Studios, you can get uh this
amazing documentary. It's going to be
really help you in your spirit to walk
and your faith. Uh let me tell you that
was the first clip
visually because I heard the sermon of
Scotty talking about the uh American
Idols
and we talk about superhero. That was my
first sermon that I heard sermon.
No, it was not visual anything.
Wow. It was that evening and I heard
that he was talking about superhero and
I was like what these guys come from you
know what these guys talking about this
ministry I want to know more about that.
The next morning I went to my computer
those big monitors that was in 2011. So
my first video that I watched it was
from Mulan the little clip. It was
kind of like a first videos
we had a long time ago and I was like
wow I never heard that. And I went to
clean up my room for my girls, you know,
cartoonist on this day.
Had a Mulan comforter or something.
Yeah. Yeah. So, we need to clean up
that.
So, yeah. Go check them out and and
Vimeo for digital download. Okay, you
guys. What about the Hindos gods? That
blue color.
That is kind of weird. Shiva. Yeah.
And that Lord's uh it's called Vishnu.
Vishn Vishnu.
Okay. Okay. And uh the Lord Krishna and
Lord Ram
Shiva, you know,
Vishnu, Krishna and Ram.
Yeah. So it's kind of blue, you know,
very very uh
Oh, the thing on the forehead,
the forehead. See, remember that
forehead?
Isn't it crazy? Like there's always the
serpent. You know, the Bible says that
the the dragon and the serpent deceive
the whole world. And you look around at
culture all around the world and they're
worshiping dragons and serpents. You got
the Mayans, they worship the snake and
the China, they got the dragon
representation
with feathers.
Feathers. Yeah.
Got snake there.
Top of the head.
So it's interesting. And let me tell I'm
going to be focus on on Shiva. And do
you know is the god of destruction?
Yeah.
Is Shiva male or female?
That's what I was wondering.
Uh I think is
I think it is like an ambiguous thing.
It looks female.
Yeah,
look it up. Sometimes they have like a
four uh four,
right?
But they're very into it. Uh because
it's
religion and also messing with yoga.
Okay. So they believe that if you want
to do this yoga post uh condolini stuff
like that, so you go with you want to be
connected with Shiva
and I don't want to be connected with
this guy. is a god of destruction,
right?
I mean, you know, here's a the first
thing that comes up on Google. Not
saying that this probably has to be
right, but I'm I'm going to guess this
probably is. This is speaking of Shiva
and Vishnu in Vishnavism and Shivaism.
God, Vishnu or Shiva respectively is
personified as male.
God, however, transcends gender in these
subschools and the male form is used as
an icon to help focus the puja or
worship. It's interesting because I the
name just sounds feminine and I when I
see that forearm one it seems like it's
always feminine but but I guess it's
ambiguous
but it's interesting again blue color.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Mhm.
Why?
Uh the the blue sky is like infinity
and their gods is like
you know like long live forever you know
things like that. That's what they were
saying. They That's why it's blue.
But I'm sure they
immortality. When are you dead? You
know, like, oh, turn blue, you know.
Yeah. When you die, you do turn blue.
But I'm sure they uh
they seen this thing, right? They didn't
probably just think, oh, what would be
an interesting god make them blue.
I know, right?
They probably saw it, right?
We need a color palette.
Yeah.
Let me tell you, it's another thing is
that you know Shiva Shamriita, they have
this star.
I totally recognize that. But it's not
pan uh pentagram.
Pentagram. No, that's
No, it's a six.
Selena.
That's right. You're right. You're
right. Because let me tell you,
yeah, you were watching my stuff.
We've done
Let me tell you Lima and Alice Crowley
is constantly talk about this thing and
and we know who's Alice Crowley. They do
what you will.
That shall be the whole law uh the whole
of the law, right? And they're really
into it. Alis Crowley with dilemma is
talking about that you're going to be I
don't know if it was worshiping and
everything but it's saying heavenly
microc cosmic and planetary forces. So
they're like praying or do rituals or
something like that through uh planets.
Yeah. Planet worship you know that's a
lot of the pagans that's what they
worship stars and things.
So they always with the elemental
five elements.
Yeah. It's interesting too that that you
know they they have love is the law
because like the law is really a
description of love, right? How do you
love God? How do you love each other?
But their love is like do whatever you
want. Like there's no limit to that
love. Um I just saw a a interesting
commercial from PlayStation and their
tagline for the PlayStation was play has
no limits.
And I was like that's an interesting
statement.
Yeah. It's like, you know, just that
thought of like do whatever you want in
the play world and it's okay.
Is that the same? You know,
I was just looking at that magical
formula. It looks like it's Yave.
Almost looks like the tetragamaton.
What is that? Yave. I mean, it looks
like Yave with the sh in there.
H.
Yeah. So crazy. Well, even Yeah. W Yave.
Y way. Um, two W's. But it's like Satan
is so cunning and subtle. Everything's
so close to you look at that and you're
like, "Oh, it's like Yahweh love." Oh,
yeah. Love.
But here's something that's interesting
about that I've kind of observed, right?
Satan can't do anything that that that
is is outside of the box of what God
designed him for, right? God designed
him to be to share about God, to be like
God. He's still trying to be like God,
but he's bent it to be himself as the
focus, but he's he was literally like,
you know, like all of our existences in
the very beginning in a perfect world
would have been many versions of showing
and pointing to the character of God.
And it's like when I see stuff like
that, it's like, man,
he still can't go outside and become
whatever he wants to become. He's got to
like be close to what God is. and then
just tweak it.
He knows there's nothing better.
Yeah.
You look at this statement, love is the
law, love under will.
Yeah.
Of course, they're meaning you're your
except it should read will under love.
Mhm.
You know,
because the reverse,
it's exactly what the Bible teaches is
like you love God and you love your
neighbor, you come last.
Die to the lust of the flesh daily and
all that.
Yeah.
I mean, why isn't Satan just like my
government's built on hate? like let's
just hate everyone. Why would you say
that? You know what I mean? Like why are
you why are you copying what God says
and then just
perverting one little tweak?
But that Yeah, that's that's the thing.
Like people think there's all this
propaganda that makes people think Satan
is scary. He's all about hate and
destruction. And so when they get into
the new age and it's all like, "No,
there's no way this is of Satan." It's
love and light. That's what it's about.
You know, I I care about other people. I
do raiki and crystals to heal people.
But that's, you know, Satan has the
powers of, you read in Revelation, it
says that there'll be signs and wonders
and miracles that are going to deceive
the whole world.
And yet people don't, we're not in our
Bibles enough. We're just seeing
the red pitchfork and all that and we
think that's the devil. But he's an
angel of light.
He's a deceiver. He's subtle.
Yeah. uh researching this and I found
this uh Krishna the fluting of the
gopies and it was illustrating this kind
of different series in the 1730s kind of
interesting is a watercolor you know
kind of like a bluish watercolor and
gold on the paper but let me tell you
they have another blue demon and a snake
with another demon okay a tomb of the
blue demons necropolis you find this
thing in in ility and the fifth century
BC
century BC that's that's probably close
to what Daniel was he in the fifth and
sixth 600 BC
because then it was like maybe like 500
years before Christ right
yeah wasn't Daniel about 500 years ago
yeah wow
so this they found this uh in the fifth
century
before Christ just look at that that's
literally like an archaic comic book
I mean when we when we look at comic
books we think oh it's just fiction or
whatever but these people had gods
painted and they're looking at it and
there's this whole story about how they
defeated and this looks like a scene out
of a comic book.
Yeah,
that's like Nightcrawler and whoever
else.
Isn't Nightcrawler blue?
Yeah,
seriously.
Well, we're going to we're going to talk
about Don't go ahead. But let me tell
you in the 1730s show how Coup it had
this thing. It's a scene of the blue
awning
that actually looks like Alistister
Crowley. You ever seen that picture of
Alistister Crowley sitting there? Have
you ever seen that? He looks crazy.
Yeah. And Oni is a Japanese demon. And
that's uh fun fact, that's how
Neon Genesis their the good guy robots
were based off of Oni. And they were
fighting angels from heaven. So there's
a complete inversion of the Bible in the
anime Neon Genesis 2.
We have a documentary on that, too.
That's right. Check it out.
Yeah. Go check out.
Interesting. It's another painting.
All the snakes and stuff down here.
Wow.
Interesting. The watercolor. Oh, there's
a a lizard tail or something he's
standing on or a snake tail.
But to me, it's like constantly the blue
character just like James Cameron had
that dream
and what the professor said, you know
what? I worship the devil. I want to I
want you tell me how you look like. It
was a blue character.
I have to point out another counterfeit.
the fact that this I don't even know if
it's a male or female, but standing on
that reptilian tail like a snake tail.
I've seen statues of Mary who's also
dressed in blue often and she's like
standing on a snake and then Catholic
paintings and you see the hand symbol up
there right the two finger salute up
there even in whatever India or you know
even in
different civilization that you found
all around the world you're going to see
the same hand signs the same She's
actually doing as above as so below.
You see that?
The other one's pointing down in the
same way and that one's pointing up.
Oh, wow. Yeah. The same fingers even for
arms.
Wow.
That was the I don't know if you guys
saw that picture of the musical show
when people sing. I think it's The Boys
Christina is had a shirt with black and
white
and it's like this.
No way.
Yeah. You haven't seen that picture?
No. Uh, I'm going to put it going to put
in there to show you guys. I have that.
So, what's going on with X-Men? X-Men
has a different character, too. Also,
Mystique. Yeah, you read my mind.
Mystique. Blue character.
Remember on their side, which is the
good guys, was the beast. And yeah,
there was
Yeah, dude.
You know what I mean? Like
crawler. Yeah. So,
you know, once again, they're saying
that these are the good guys, you know,
these mutants that look like demons. And
the bad guy in the movie Apocalypse
says, "I've been called Yahweh."
The one that can read your mind.
And he's coming with the four horsemen
to
Magneto. Everybody is if I am lifted up,
everybody is drawn to me, right?
Magneto. Like I mean there's like so
many parallels in there
to to Yeah, that's I believe you know
that's like a description of God and
but they flipped it like he was the one
who went rogue and you know went away
from the other guys but yeah.
Oh yeah.
What about
Dr. Manhattan, right? He's he's a evil
guy, you know, evil doctor. He hates
humanity and he wants to destroy.
And it was like three guys. I don't know
if it's like Trinity or something. I
mean, I I haven't watched that movie or
anything,
but it's another character is a blue
Well, he's got the all sing.
He's a destroyer.
Destroyer.
Okay. And Watchmen is Is it called
Watchmen?
Mhm.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. Watchmen.
Is that the people? Is that the blue
people or is that's like the whole
series?
Okay. I was going to say Watchmen. I
don't know if it's like in the Bible,
but some of these extra biblical books
like Enoch and stuff, they call the
angels the watchers and stuff. So, I
don't know if there's any relation to
that.
Yeah. What about another cartoons for
children?
I don't know.
Interesting. Monsters.
Monsters Inc. I mean, the blue guy with
the horns.
But guess what? He's your friend.
Yeah, he's a friend, bro.
He's your friend.
He's like a little kitty cat.
What about this guy?
Wow. another alien.
It's another alien, you know, Stitch,
right?
And he was actually like this like
really mean character, wasn't he? I
never actually saw this, but I remember
um somebody showed a clip for some
reason and he was like evil. He was like
I think he was supposed to eat the world
or something,
right? I heard you reading something
about
But then she becomes friends with him.
Is that kind of the story line?
Because he I believe that he came to
destroy the earth, but he became friends
with the human and kind of like love and
everything.
Decided not to. That's interesting what
Wikipedia talks about in the movie has a
nicknames, right? And right here in the
end, it says little monster and
abomination.
Abomination. They call him abomination
right there.
Wow. I don't ever even hear that word
outside the Bible.
Abomination.
Yeah. If you hear the word abomination,
somebody's probably, you know, using it
from the terminology of the Bible. It's
kind of interesting because his his name
uh you know because he was he was
created in the lab or something like
that is experiment 626
no
66 and two sixes.
Yeah.
Oh
yeah. 626s
in Mexico we have some guy says blue
demon
wrestling.
That's funny.
You know the very famous guy. And we
have another guy said blue devils. Uh
it's from uh basketball
North Carolina.
Yeah. Duke
Duke University.
Yeah.
But why blue de Oh, it's not red uh
devils,
right?
Why blue devils,
right? Remember those guys?
The blue man. There's a trinity again.
Oh, really?
There's more of them.
Is there more? I always see three,
though.
I think I thought there was five.
Yeah,
I think that when they performed their
Maybe not.
Yeah, three with music. You know what?
My favorite color of shirts that I own
is blue.
Oh, we I knew it.
I always wear blue.
Got on that. Sorry.
Am I wearing blue today?
No.
Red.
What about this guy? Vision.
Uh we talk about um Avengers. I think we
have a a a video you did some LED life
and you guys check them out. I was
researching about this and it's blue and
red, right?
And just please pay attention how he
become alive.
Okay, watch this clip.
[Music]
I'm sorry. That was odd.
Thank you. You helped create this.
I've had a vision. A whirlpool that
sucks in all hope of life. And at its
center is that
what the gem?
It's the mind stone. It's one of the six
infinity stones. The greatest power in
the universe unparalleled in its
destructive capabilities.
Then why would you bring
Stark is right?
Oh, it's definitely the end times.
You think I'm a child of Ultron.
You're not.
I'm not Altron. I'm not Jarvis.
I am.
Are you
on our side?
I don't think it's that simple. I am on
the side of life. Maybe I am a monster.
I don't think I'd know if I were one and
not what you are and not what you
intended.
So there may be no way to make you trust
me.
Wow.
So who gave the life to this guy?
Thor.
Thor was it?
He grabbed the, you know, some power and
just grab it to the capsule or something
like that. A womb or something and just
came alive. Right.
But interesting. I thought say I had a
vision.
I had a dream, a vision. And that's why
I decided to this guy. Right.
So it's like a prophecy and a and like a
virgin birth almost. Yeah.
He comes out saying I am and I'm on the
side of life.
You're right. Yeah.
He's a bad guy, right?
Yeah. It's
Well, he's on the Avengers side.
Yeah. They're making him the good guy,
but
Well, our hypothesis is that he's not uh
he's not on the side of God,
right? You know,
fun fact, Scotty was in that scene um as
the Hulk.
A lot of people think you look like that
guy. I don't know his name. Oh, really?
This is what he said. He said, "Hey, was
it seems like it's in the uh end times?"
Oh, yeah. He did say what he said.
Crazy.
Wow.
Now, I'm gonna have this clip. Pay
attention.
Just watch the clip. I'm not going to
say anything. It's kind of interesting.
They say, "Hey, I'm here for for life."
And things like that, right?
Do you know I don't know what this is?
Not really. I know it's not of this
world, but it powered Loki's staff gave
you your abilities. But its true nature
is a mystery. And yet, it is part of me.
Are you afraid of it?
I wish to understand it. The more I do,
the less it controls me one day.
Who knows? I may even control it.
I really pay attention. But this guy is
kind of like a philosopher guy. When he
talks, he's not like let's go fight, you
know? He's like more
thinking like talking to you very nice.
But it's kind of interesting that he is
blue, right? Red and talks to you very
nice, softly, intelligent guy. And he's
talking to a woman. And I don't know if
you guys pay attention, but underneath
of the scene, he's in the kitchen.
There are two apples.
Interesting.
I'm going to play again. I'm going to
play again. H.
Do you know I don't know what this is?
Not really. I know it's not of this
world, but it powered Loki's staff gave
you your abilities. But it's true nature
is a mystery. And yet it is part of me.
Are you afraid of it?
I wish to understand it. The more I do,
the less it controls me. One day,
who knows? I may even control it.
So, it's kind of interesting this scene.
You know, he's talking to you very
philosophy and and to a woman talking to
a woman and they have two apples there.
Yeah. There's nothing by accident in a
movie.
Yeah.
The camera just barely pans down enough
so you can see it too.
Mhm. Yeah. Just just a little bit. So
the reason I just want to you know
create this you know slides and
everything it's kind of interesting how
how
James Cameron had this dream how this
teacher had this like I want to see what
I worship you know I worship the devil I
want to see the pain
blue character blue character and this
cartoonish these movies and all stuff is
a blue character and Lord Shiva the
destruction is a blue guy is
But it's bringing some message.
It's just the message is like do not
worship the creator
worship me.
So confusion
deceiving
and what we I just want to finish with a
Bible verse because we need to be we
need to be alert but also we need to be
equipped
you know with the armor of God.
Amen. And let me tell you in Ephesians
chapter 6 verse 10 and 14 it says
finally be strong in the Lord and his
mighty power. Put on the full armor of
God so that you can take your stand
against the devil's schemes. So our
struggle is not against the flesh or
blood but against to the rulers and
against the authorities against the
power of this dark world and against the
spiritual forces of evil and the
heavenly realms. Therefore, put in the
full armor of God that when the day of
evil comes, you be able to stand your
ground and after you have done
everything to stand, stand firm. So what
a beautiful promise that the you know uh
the Bible said you know what when you
have a
situation in your life it's kind of not
just like struggles and all stuff but
let me tell you sometimes you have some
weird happenings
in life and it's going to be sometimes
shaking
and the the Bible say hey put the armor
of God and I think it's not just in
those moments I think we need to ask the
Holy Spirit
every morning right to be baptized for
the Holy Spirit to please God help me
with I need the armor of God. I mean, we
need to spend time with the Lord because
let me tell you, the enemy is going to
come right now. Maybe we can say, you
know, I'm strong right now on the word
of God. You know, I'm strong in my
faith.
Let me tell you, situation comes in our
lives.
You know, we're married, we got kids, we
got spouse, you know, we have things,
you know, the enemy is going to come to
destroy us. This is the whole point. I
want to destroy us. and all the stuff
that we see on the entertainment, we
need to be be careful what we're
watching, what we listen, because
they're gonna be very deceiving.
It also is making a cult to stand up
against evil. I mean, if you just simply
consider the majority of the mainstream
media that everybody's paying attention
to, there is some very evil concepts in
there. I mean, where's the people
standing up for that? Where's the people
going like, "Hey, I disagree with this
and this is not good." You know, it's
like as a Christian, we need to stand
for what we believe in, not just be
silent and, you know,
take it basically. It's like I think we
need to to to do what we can to to
make God's ways
prominent.
Amen. Amen. Yeah. You know, it's
interesting that like an atheist would
walk out of a movie if it turned into
some Christian movie like Pure Flakes.
They'd be like, "I'm I'm not going to
watch this garbage." But the Christian
world will pay money to go into these
movies that have a message attacking God
and then defend it. Often times on our
channel, you look in the comments and
it's like, "You guys are the reason that
nobody wants to be a Christian. You're
legalist and all this." And it's like,
we're simply pointing out that this is
an attack on God.
Yeah.
And you're going to defend that and and
fight against your brother who's
exposing the darkness.
And we're not attacking other
Christians.
We're not slamming. We're attacking like
a system of evil that's promoting other
gods and abominable things
and they're defending them.
Yeah. It's like defend. I hope that you
defend God with the same tenacity that
you would defend this junk. You know,
it's like where where are we standing
for God?
Yeah. Wow.
That's a rhetorical question.
Yeah. Well, it's based on an idea that I
know better. It's just fake stuff. So,
if I take it all in, doesn't affect me.
Look at the life of Solomon.
Totally knew better. Yeah. Surrounded
himself with it anyway. Did it affect
him? Yeah. I wrote a book of the Bible
that was like, I regret all that stuff
that I did.
Mhm.
And you I should have lived my life
differently. And my advice to you is
don't go there.
Yeah.
Smartest man in the world ever to set
foot on this planet was sending his
babies into the fire.
I mean, that's a solemn thought that it
wasn't his intelligence that prevented
him from doing evil.
On the same flip side of the coin, the
atheist isn't going to watch Bible Man
even though it's fiction.
They will choose not to watch it because
that message or whatever. And yet, we
watch a bad message and justify it that
it's fiction. That's a
good point. And the thing is that I also
I I see is idolatry.
Because you know I mean I was very
hooked in superhero stuff you know
and maybe people that practicing yoga
they don't know about this. I mean you
kind of yoking with with the spirit of
uh Shiva you know when you're doing yoga
you know poses and stuff like that. So
it's idolatry is I think is the main
thing and the devil Satan is using for
thousands of years. I mean you you you I
I mean you read the stories of Israel
how it was defeating because of worship
idols.
Yeah.
So um we need to be careful.
So I just want to share with you guys uh
these little things about those
connection. You know sometimes you
you're driving or something and you oh
yeah I watch this documentary. Oh I
watched this video and what about this
character? What? I was like, "Wow, let's
let's make things. Let's research." And
I found more stuff. And you were saying
more things and I'm like, "Well, I
didn't put it in on the presentation."
But, uh, go check them out. Thank you so
much for watching our video or LED live.
Uh, if you want to support this ministry
to make more videos like this, please go
to Patreon uh/ Little Life Studios. Uh,
go check them out. And please don't
forget to like and subscribe and share
this video because I know your family's
going to be blessed. And also, we have a
new YouTube channel for kids. That's
right. Check out Little Light Kids.
We're building more and more videos
because a lot of people ask us, "Well,
what can we watch?" Well, we're in the
works of making educational biblical
content that your children can watch
that's safe for them. And it's really
easy for you to help support this work.
Just go to our Facebook page or our
YouTube page and subscribe to that
channel. Share it with somebody. If you
got little kids or nephews or nieces or
grandchildren, share it with them and uh
help us create awareness about the
things of God and give positive things
for people to watch.
Amen.
And also, you want to support us uh go
to lightwear uh.shop and you're going to
find a really cool t-shirts to where you
witness to share with other people and
then start a conversation to share your
faith. Thanks so much and we'll see you
next week with another powerful video.
Bye.
[Music]
There has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world. And in
1999, a movie titled The Matrix hit the
world stage.
These stories are often told and seen
over and over again. Is it simply just
to make money, or is there something
more nefarious behind it?
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh yeah.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
And also we have teachers. First too, we
have a a go support uh a little
lightwear.
Little light go lightwear shop.
You want to talk about the original?
Let's do it.
[Music]